[Music]
voting for the NME Awards has begun
hurry all nice of course it [ __ ]
yuria nice hey how's the pissed-off
don't try to call me to Fitz and they
get still can't pass me Oh king of the
youtubes you're coming through smelling
like poopoo most of you once again
didn't understand the hidden message of
my race entity bro video this punk [ __ ]
[ __ ] or see anime
hey guys are see enemy here we've got a
big big story coming from digi bro I'm
the greatest anime youtuber if you don't
think so
[ __ ] you books they look like the white
is [ __ ] Isis member of the sea
welcome to Giga
vs. Subaru era manga sensei era longa
sensei era manga saint seiya manga
sense8 era manga sensei you're a manga
sensei I don't [ __ ] that thing [ __ ]
sucks I [ __ ] hate that things and
stuff like that what the hell
so apparently you say run goes with
everything my hero academia I hero
academia my hero academia my hero my
hero my hero and I hear my hair at my
hip I buy my boku no hero academia
we've got an issue people will come by
and just hammer you into the ground with
personal insults nice [ __ ] batter
guide and then gig ik walks up to me and
then he just bites my hand and the bread
along with it and he says boobs' I'll be
hosting a rooftop party Anime Expo we
got kicked out of the party
you know she's 12 Roy
I requested lewd images from a 12 year
old girl it's cool that this dude has so
much passion for drawing a 12 year old
genitals avatar the last airbender is an
anime [ __ ] you I'm finally here I
finally get to make using the eye hi
character feels so authentic this is
gonna be insane this is going to be fan
wars to the max naruto uzumaki Ichigo
Kurosaki
the winner is Naruto Uzumaki
[Music]
this is Naruto fans right now do you see
their faces in real life though they
would never fight they would never fight
they would be best buddies 'ghost your
fan theories to tumblr and so me as we
wait for the police to arrive in his
time to wrap this up by Jonny signing
out Chiba
thanks for watching have an awesome date
sayonara stay frosty
so look if I had to sum up whatever
points I was trying to make you all make
me so happy to be in the same circle
critters I [ __ ] love every second
it's been a long journey it's probably
the happiest I've ever been in my life
and this to me friends is why you should
watch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]